Cindy we've spoken before but we're
going to recap everything you're a
sponsor
wait for a person you grew up where in
Highland Park here yeah it's by Eagle up
you could go a long time yeah like 25
years 30 years Holly 55 what what Bernie
your original book with who are the
circumstances they've got you
you seem like coming down here like to
get by oh my
and then go back home with what age were
you when you first got involved in drugs
I had just turned 21 it's enough you
know Tina
until one day I started seeing
introduced into heroin
and you tried it
about
it's instinctive chocolate you grew up
with one parent or parents oh my brother
while we lived in Santa Monica and my
mom my dad and my brothers are living
[Applause]
just like regular family like no no use
huh no no no we had like my mom and dad
they were good to us my dad used to take
us on trips we go to like Big Bear or we
go Lake Isabella he was always taking us
places to a beach camping and stuff to
the mountains
we went she like Jahangir or not we
scored a chunk of Canyon a lot but no
like my mom or dad or my dad passed away
from cancer and she doesn't attend but
they were married forever my dating tree
while my dad drink beer but um and smoke
cigarettes but nobody in my family did
drugs is there any history of addiction
[Music]
like we weren't around it either where
we lived there wasn't like any people
around that I saw Jim late start
payments you too to suffer you at 21
when you first got involved in drugs did
it's just a kick in and take home yeah
and nobody and I was already like um oh
I was already out of school but like
throughout junior high in high school
I still didn't know anything about
heroin I didn't know anybody that I hung
around with I never had any boyfriends
that did it um like places I went um
people I saw or were around dated in my
in my neighborhood I didn't know any
place that sold it you know it was like
it just wasn't even thought of over
there but I knew it was bad what is your
drug
and you any other other ghosts when I
would get not good usually it was for
possession well there's people that help
you and sometimes are like tits or
something to get money and there's a few
PYD do a regular customers are you yeah
but um not always
[Music]
yes I have to they have to live usually
nothing and you've been to this one time
do you have any crazy stories things are
happening danger
not now but maybe when I was like burst
down here like I I've gotten cards with
a couple of times where someone pulled a
gun on ya what Dave started out being
nice and and and then afterwards I put
the gun away you know just like just
scare scare me with it but no one ever
like hurt me
and
what would you like to see for yourself
the next five years you imagine a
different life for you yeah what mom me
and my boyfriend that I was with we kind
of like haven't been together for a
couple months but I kind of thought that
was gonna be my last relationship
he was gonna take me away from here i I
just hope that maybe when we get back
together he doesn't use
we live it together you know
[Music]
get away from here you start like a
little business
so you're sleepy we're okay yeah I got a
chance I have a brand new team
yeah that's something I still I'm still
on the street
I'm stealing yeah it's not getting any
better down here yeah
so the heroin you actually even enjoy it
do you think I've been unmended on now
for like three years but unfortunately
I'm not all the way up to here I still
do it a little bit but I mean the method
on does help you you know but I don't
know I still do it a little bit I think
it's just because I've been doing it for
so long that that's just part of my way
of life you know it's just part of my
routine
our daily routine yeah I have two
daughters very perky um I was talking to
my big daughter but she doesn't know
everything like she doesn't know about
him on the street or living in a tent
Christmas she wouldn't like it she be
coming down here trying to chick to take
me away she's always trying to help me
she'll send me like money grounds and
stuff and she'll ask me mom can I send
you things you know and if she doesn't
hear from me for a little while she gets
worried and she thinks like she's happy
because I'm a demented on program but
she doesn't know that I still need
being like completely honest with her
just I do I tell her it's just so much
you know
because I'm not training
her shoes
and no matter what she still loves me
she doesn't turn her back on me she just
wants you know as to have a like a good
relationship and she wants to be able to
see me
all the time you know and us to be like
normal she come to visit she's wanted
she's tried you and I back out at the
last me
I'm just I don't know I get scared I
guess cuz I don't want her to see me in
my addiction you know I guess I can't do
it
and everybody says Cindy she doesn't
care she just wants to see her mom she
loves you she doesn't care about nothing
else where you live or you know you just
let her here a month why are you trying
to take that brother
but it's just hard you know cuz I don't
I don't know her
she's already like 27 years old she's
doing real good she's uh she works out
of yogurt she's a manager of
and she's massage therapist
she's doing really
like yeah maybe I won't be here forever
but it just seems like it cuz it's been
so long